i moved back in with my parents and they
had to take me to the doctor because i
just wouldn't get out of bed
i was not eating i was so
so depressed and um then i went through
a whole phase where
i talked about this on one of my youtube
shows was i got um
addicted to valium because it was the
only thing that
it numbed me through the pain and
what that go on for i mean i think this
is a really good question because
heartbreak is something that
you know everyone experiences at some
level and sometimes it's higher than
others so like
when you reach that point where it's so
bad and you
can't function and it's hard to do
anything like how long did that go on
for
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
today on the show we have caitlyn
bristow i have been a fan of hers
for so many years i just like even all
the way back to
well would have been back to when she
was on the bachelor and
then the bachelorette and just seeing
her
authenticity and her humor and
i love canadians and canadians to me are
always like the most
funny people and kind and it was an
honor to get to talk to her today
all of my thoughts and perspectives on
her
are true i mean she is she is that
person
and so in the episode we really dive
into
relationships your own personal work
your own self-care work
uh what you do to get stronger and more
independent and confident as a person
and of course we're drinking wine
because we both make wine
so enjoy the show i have my rose here
melting ice cubes because i forgot to
chill oh my gosh
i love the color of your rose thanks
well i mean
okay so i uh when when we did the whole
like branding for rose
it was or the research it was
drinking 30 different kinds it was
looking at the bottle
it was looking at the color it was the
taste of course
um and so it was like a whole process so
the color was a part of it
but then you can see like my wrote
because i i have my own label
yes i have somnium which is like
something i've been working on since
2009.
um so this is my own property this is my
own whole project this is this is my
whole everything
i have partners with this one and so the
color is totally different
with mine um this comes from my estate
grapes
and it's done the sagne style where they
bleed off
and uh and then oh there you go and
but this is made from this is made from
grapes that make rose so this is from
france so that's awesome yeah there we
go
i am really curious how that all
happened for you like how did
how did you like my framing here with
this
some people are only going to be
listening but some people will
eventually watch this
um how how did you get into wine spade
and sparrow first maybe start off with
how it got in how you got into it
basically i did about 10 years in the
restaurant
business so i was in the industry from
the second i moved to vancouver
i was 19 years old and it was able to
you know have the hours that i needed to
i was going out there to dance and so i
learned a lot about the menu we had to
study everything learned a lot about the
wines
and then eventually i just kept working
my way up in the restaurant industry
where i was managing and then training
servers myself so
i was always trained by a sommelier
learning like all these things about
wine because about four hours from
vancouver it's called wine country and
it's in the okanagan and it's like
basically my happy place favorite place
on earth and we would always go down
there on like work trips and learn about
the wines and
and i just always loved um
the stories that came along with it just
like
how to pair it with different foods i
just really started loving
it and and what's funny is my mom used
to always drink wine growing up i always
loved it she had a glass of wine with
dinner while she was cooking
and i was always like that stuff smells
like disgusting but once i got into it
and learned more about it i just fell in
love with it so
fast forward to coming off of um the
show
bachelorette and trying to like navigate
what i was gonna do i obviously
made so many mistakes of like oh this
company's gonna i just sounded so
canadian there by the way
um it's okay i love canadians and we're
gonna talk about canadians because i
love
canadians okay good um but i was like
oh this company's gonna pay me to post
about flat tummy tea
like i don't use it but cool that's like
a great paycheck for me compared to the
restaurant industry
and i you know i had to learn very
quickly that that's not how you build a
brand or
if you want to do something big later
you know after that kind of show you
have to kind of prove yourself and
get your audience to trust you and only
like stay true to what you love and and
build something from that so
i was like wine okay so i started doing
the podcast around drinking wine and
chatting with people
and then i just saw how conversations
just are always so much better with a
glass of wine in my opinion i'm sure you
agree
and then everybody kind of said to me
like why don't you start your own label
or do something with a wine brand and i
was like
why why am i not doing that so i
have a really amazing team that has
helped me and uh
we kind of just started in napa sat in a
little
hole in the wall and came up with the
name which was like the most random
thing in the world we just had a list of
like 100 things that meant something to
me we just started putting things
together and
came up with that and i was like i like
the sound of that and that's kind of how
it happened
huh why do you like spade and spirit
like how did those make the list
yeah okay so so many different things i
still have the list i look back on and
i'm like
it's hilarious because it was obviously
after some wine but um so it's
okay it's always a hard story to explain
to because first of all
i've got these birds tattooed on my arms
oh yeah um
and a lot of people kind of knew that
from me on the show that i had both
sides
yeah on both sides yeah and so what i
thought
was um when i got them done the tattoo
artist told me it's the only bird that
remembers how to fly home
and i've lived in so many different
places and i'm very close to my family
and so i was like i
love that meaning and so i got them
tattooed and then
down the road as i'm like always telling
people they're sparrows they're actually
swallows and swallows is the bird
that remembers how to fly home and i was
like ah sparrow sounds cooler okay
and um so anytime i'm with my family and
drinking wine we're
always playing cards always always
always it's like our favorite thing to
do it still is my favorite thing to do
while drinking
wine and the spade was always my
favorite suit because it was the most
powerful suit in the deck
and so we were writing down like my
tattoos we wrote down swallows we wrote
down spades
we wrote down sparrows and all those
things just started coming together
and i was like you know i always want to
like remember where i came from and i
always loved going home and we always
played cards and then that just kind of
came together
and and i again that's what i loved
about the wine industry was hearing all
these people's stories about how it came
to be
and so i was like okay that one's gonna
stick
that's so important to know to have a
story because there's
a million wines there's you know a
million different varietals there's so
many different places all over the world
that make amazing wine and there is so
much good wine so it's like
what separates you from the rest is why
is the reason why and the story behind
it and the authenticity of the brand
and so um that's so that's really that's
really
important that you have that story do
you remember what you first started
drinking
i do and it's my like yellow tail white
wine
yeah like um there is one i don't know
if this is a canadian brand or if it's
um i'm blanking on the name it starts
with the a but it's like
basically a wine cooler and then
and then i switched to yellow tail
yellow tail yeah yellow tail do you
remember that one you skipped right over
to buck chuck
i skipped right over to book chuck and
it was so cute because i went home
not too long ago and i went to visit my
dad and my dad actually doesn't drink
and but he always
knows to have wine in the house because
first of all my so my parents are
remarried and my mom and my stepdad are
like the wine lovers
and my dad knows that so he always has
wine when we come over
and it's so cute because like he
obviously doesn't know what stuff to get
me and he always goes i got your
favorite the yellow tail
thinking i still drink that it's
adorable
and now of course especially like being
in the industry and i've seen
because i've followed you on social
media for a long time because i just
you're just hilarious and again you're
canadian so
i love you um and um you know going to
napa and seeing you be
like there's so many good places there
so
do you have any do you drink red wine oh
i love red wine i mean
i have rose you have the pinot noir and
you have
uh pinot grigio yes yes but what do you
drink the most of
i drink the most of pinot noir um i also
love a cab but pinot seems to be my
favorite
lately um i'm trying to think of i've
been to so many places and now oh you
know where i
really loved going and i love their
pinot and i love their cab as well
is um duck horn oh yeah have you been to
that winery there
i haven't been there um but i've been to
about a million in the valley and
that didn't make the million list yet
but um yeah duckhorn has a really great
it's a super stable brand and i think
i mean i wouldn't have i wouldn't have
actually chosen to go there just because
i like to try
unique ones and like go to different
speakers yeah exactly
but i was on a trip with revolve and
they all took us to like a dinner and
wine pairing there
and just again hearing the man speak
about
where it all started and just like how
it came together and
trying their wines and all the food it
was incredible so i had a really great
experience there
i feel like i don't maybe you can share
like some of your first wine tastings
but
i feel like that is the transition point
for someone who
maybe kind of drinks wine and then they
but then when you go do a tasting and
you hear about
how long it takes what it takes to grow
it how rare that one vintage is
um all of the effort and the layers and
the time it takes and the farming and
the
you know everything from then crush on
and how long you leave it in barrel and
then bottle and just
the nuances and the little little little
things that go on
i feel like you know that's when you go
holy crap
that's not just like any wine there was
a lot of love put in that and it's
really special
that's so true everything you said i'm
just nodding my head going exactly like
i feel like when you hear about all
those things it just immediately
makes you appreciate it more and it
makes it taste better because you just
you truly appreciate where it's come
from
yeah yeah that's that's part of that
story right but i
um i i love i love the tastings whenever
i go back to napa or whenever i go
anywhere
i even though i have my own vineyard and
i make you know i have two labels now
although i'm i mean i'd love to go to
this one because it's in france so
um i'm not mad at that visit either but
i don't i i'll go up to my property for
sure and we'll do like some fun tasting
and i might have to check in on some red
blends or some white or whatever's going
on
but i love to do new tastings because
they're fun the caves i mean
you just accidentally get a little too
drunk yep
yes that's the best part and then you
just like have the best sleep of your
life after
i love canadians so growing up racing
um go-karts i raced in canada all the
time and there were so many canadian
drivers
and so from a very young age i was like
i think canadians are the best
you guys are the most friendly you are
also
very funny i you know i'd sit here and
nod like
thank you it's true it's true i'm
talking about you
and some other canadians why is that
like what is it about growing what is it
about canada
i honestly have no idea i feel like
for me personally i grew up in a very
weird not weird it just like a small
town that felt very normal to me at the
time but obviously i didn't know
anything else but there's
really not a lot to do there um and the
closest city was edmonton and there's
really not a lot to do
there either as much as i love my
hometown and province but
there's some good restaurants in
edmonton i used to race in edmonton
there was the streets of the airport
that i used to race at
there's some really fancy restaurant
downtown that i remember eating at each
year
really yeah like a really nice one i
feel like they might have even had
tasting menus or something
okay because first of all where you
probably raced was right by
um where i grew up which is called leduc
that's like right where the airport is
like my dad's backyard faces
the airport okay um but yeah i've been
to your hometown
i i will say yes you have i will say
edmonton does have some good restaurants
that's
that's fair um but i just think i
was forced to like have this imagination
and personality because i literally just
like all my friends lived on a farm and
i feel like all we did was like play out
in the field
and i don't know if that has anything to
do with it but that's something that my
mom told me once like
she was like you always just had such a
personality and and imagination
and that's like all how all my friends
were and i'm not sure if that has
anything to do with it
but i'm i'm trying to think of something
i don't know like tell me what um
what were your high school parties like
oh like
you would go out to the middle of
nowhere and just have a huge
bonfire and we called it a party yeah
and just like mirrors and country music
in the middle of nowhere with a bonfire
oh my gosh
yeah i can relate growing up in the
like corn fields of illinois yeah
you just um yeah it's just a bonfire in
the backyard or
gosh i remember this one time we had a
hole dug for the keg and it was this
empty
empty barn and it was one of the guys
parents owned it
and uh they dropped the keg in there and
had a board to put over the top if
someone came and so sure enough there's
tons of people at this party and the
cops show up
yeah and so everybody starts scattering
right and i remember
and i ran to the woods and i think i
walked like
across highways like for like miles to
get back to somewhere
safe and i remember the flashlight on me
going if you run it's a felony and i'm
like
well i better run faster
are you out random that's amazing what a
genius idea to slide
a board over put it in the ground like
how did we not think of that
i don't know somebody was obviously a
little too sober when they thought of
that
yeah that's very smart what did you guys
call it because we called it bush
parties
oh um well there was pre-gaming
do you remember yes horse you can't go
anywhere without pre-gaming no
and then it was just like bonfires we
just called them like
bonfires like yeah there's a bonfire at
so-so's house yeah
yeah do you have siblings yeah i have
well i have um
one older sister and then she's got two
kids my niece and nephew who i'm
so obsessed with and then um my parents
it's funny because
so i've my parents actually divorced
when i was like 17
almost 18 which is kind of like an older
age and my parents kind of remained
friends like obviously a little like
difficulty through the initial
paperwork but like my dad would still
come over for sunday night dinners
and christmas and then he met someone
and my mom met someone
and even like going on the show where i
have to introduce these guys to my
family like
all my stepdad and my dad are together
they actually stayed at each other's
houses
my dad and my stepdad like go golfing
and
the ladies really are the nicest people
in the world
they even divorce well yeah it was it
was i feel very lucky for that um
and it's it's funny because like i
totally don't know how my parents even
worked for that long they're so
so opposite um but again like i always
remember like a healthy relationship
between them and i just feel like i was
so fortunate for that my mom is an
absolute firecracker and my dad is like
salt of the earth just so grounded
calm and loving and just like they're
i mean so is my mom but my mom's just
very much like a personality too
and my dad's just so quiet and calm so
my sister's kind of a combination of
them both and then i have six step
sisters from
from my parents remarrying wow yeah
yeah family plays such a huge role i
mean i think that
you know i've been learning so much
about um
uh you know personality dynamics your
own personal
sort of attachment styles your own you
know
you know how you're shaped from sort of
trauma bonds as a kid which
almost every single this is must i i i
can't imagine having a kid because
well i can but i can't because you're
gonna every single one of them is gonna
have something right every single kid is
gonna have like
the good and the bad and there's you're
gonna love them too much you're not
gonna love them enough like there's
almost no way to be perfect about it and
so
um like does any of that i mean the fact
that they divorced that's a big deal but
you obviously experienced a really
positive
childhood what um like what were the
things that that taught you that you can
do you remember thinking like thank god
that i saw this when i was a kid
and then what were the things that
you're like okay i think
i need to fix that yeah oh gosh i'm so
trust me i'm like the biggest advocate
for therapy
and learning everything about myself i
go all the time i absolutely love it i
love my therapist and i've learned
so much about myself from doing that and
and
why i am the way i am and it's
interesting because
i i have grown up something that
something positive i take away from it
is that i saw healthy conflict i saw
healthy relationships
and um both of my parents were very much
um they are very encouraging of me just
being who i was they never told me to
follow a blueprint or that i had to go
to school for this or that
this is what i was supposed to do they
were very much like letterfly and i was
always just like the kind of person who
just
got up and did what i wanted and i'm
gonna go here because of this i'm going
to take this opportunity and i don't
want to tie myself down because what if
it takes away from
another path i'm supposed to be on and
my parents were really really great
about allowing me to just be completely
who i was
and that i would be successful no matter
what just being me
um which i i absolutely love um
so much obviously to work on and
that would be like i think
i think um my mom wanted a lot of times
to be a friend
instead of a mom um which is obviously
amazing because
we would do everything together but i
think sometimes i needed
more of the structure um and more maybe
discipline
and my dad i'm trying to my dad i
honestly every time i talk
about my dad i could cry because i'm
just like he's the most perfect man who
has like done
nothing he is an angel on this earth but
he's just um i don't know maybe
maybe the same thing for him that he was
kind of too much like
like i was a little bit of a degenerate
when i was 18 years old and as much as i
was an
adult at that time um he kind of totally
believed in like me learning my own
lessons
um so again could have used a little
more structure and
instead of just getting away with doing
terrible things
um there's a lot of things too that came
up through my childhood with
with being a dancer because i did ballet
jazz
tap hip-hop lyrical modern i did it all
and my mom was a professional ballerina
and i think
um what really what was something i
really struggled with growing up was
always comparing myself to the girl next
to me and their
body type and what uh you know because
if you're a ballerina you need to be
tiny and as tiny as i was i was always
looking to the next girl
and we would stand in the mirrors for
you know four hours a day
you know comparing our bodies and
thinking of what we need to look like
and
being told at dance competitions so this
you need to look this certain way have
your hair done this way and you know it
was just always about
image and i think that's what i kind of
struggled with
growing up and coming into my own
through my 20s was i was just so focused
on
um image and and body image and
what i needed to look like to succeed
hmm
so tough mm-hmm i hear you
yeah how what age were you when you went
on the
bachelor i was and i
thank god i was this age but i was 29
and i feel like 28 29 was really when i
started like coming into who i really
was and
had been doing therapy since 26 and
obviously like still had such a ways to
go but really
went into that at a time where um i was
probably the most confident and i that
i'd ever been and
had you know as much self-worth as i
needed to go into that
because i always say i if i would have
gone on that show any earlier
i would have been a mess i would have
been a mess i didn't have thick skin i
didn't have
the self-worth i needed i was easily
manipulated i trusted everybody and
i just think it was like like i always
say
thank god i i was that age going into
that show
how did you get there i mean everybody
would want to know that i think like how
did you get there and
was it an epiphany or a couple of them
it was at the bottom oh yeah it was
an absolute rock bottom it was i you
know i
i grew up dancing so hard that's all i
ever wanted to do that's why i moved to
vancouver i got a scholarship to dance
with the company
i was um cheerleading in the cfl the
canadian football league
and i was just like loving yes
nailed it
yeah and i was just like every day like
that's just what i focused on and that's
why i
didn't go to college that's why i didn't
go to pursue any other career because i
was just so dedicated to dance
and so i you know turned 25
maybe 26 and i started realizing like
okay nothing's happening like i
i still love dancing and i'm getting
small opportunities here and there but
nothing that's really gonna like
you know make it as a career for me and
so then i met a guy
and he was a professional hockey player
classic canadian
and i was like okay
you know like this is an opportunity i
can like
be with somebody that i love i can give
up on my dreams it's not going to happen
and i kind of just stopped everything i
was doing
i lost a lot of friends i lost the dream
of dancing
i i didn't lose my job i chose to leave
my job
and i moved wherever he needed to go and
he ended up signing in germany and
by the time i headed out to germany i
was just a shell of myself
i felt completely lost i had nothing
going
i didn't have any like income i was
financially
emotionally relying on him i was
in germany i didn't speak the language
we weren't in like a touristy place so
um no one spoke english the
girls on the team were a little bit
clicky in their german group because
like
they all spoke it and got along there
and sounds impressive
it was so hard and i would go to the
grocery store and one of my favorite
things to do is cook
and i couldn't even read labels um i
couldn't afford
a phone um so my
boyfriend at the time like gave me his
old one but i could only run it off
wi-fi
so i couldn't like look things up when i
was at the grocery store it was so
terrible
and i ended up i do i'm nothing against
crossfit i'm just it's not for me and i
ended up joining crossfit because the
guys that ran it spoke english and i was
like it's going to keep me sane to just
hear
english conversation to be able to talk
to somebody
and that's that was like the only thing
i would do
and besides drink wine i would drink
wine and i didn't have the money to go
travel if it's red or white it was
i honestly was like i was like i'm in
europe i should
like he's gone on the road for weeks so
if i could travel but i had no income
and i didn't want to ask him for money
and
um i just i just was so empty
and that started to show in the
relationship i became so insecure
um i just didn't have anything
that filled my tank and so we ended up
breaking up and i was
i mean i was an absolute mess because it
was at the time
the love of my life i had given up
everything
i was you know i didn't know how i was
gonna go back to work what i was gonna
do what i was passionate about i had no
education
i had to move back in with my parents i
had no support like from him
in the breakup which i mean i don't i
didn't expect anything
did you did he break up with you or did
you break up with him
it was kind of like a he broke up with
me
but i knew that was the right thing like
i knew it couldn't work
but i never wanted to believe that and
when i moved back i think that you
kind of got to like a co-dependency kind
of state oh yes
at 1 000 and it's just not who i am
at all and and i moved back in with my
parents and they had to take me to the
doctor because i just wouldn't get out
of bed
i was not eating i was so so depressed
and
um then i went through a whole phase
where i talked about this
on one of my youtube shows was i got
addicted to valium because
it was the only thing that it numbed me
through
the pain and what that go on for i mean
i think this is a really good question
because heartbreak is something that
you know everyone experiences at some
level and sometimes it's higher than
others so like
when you reach that point where it's so
bad and you
can't function and it's hard to do
anything like how long did that go on
for
yeah it um longer than i would have
wanted it to but
it was probably it was a few
months of of that which is a long
period of time to go through you know
dropping weight not eating and just
being
so depressed and taking something like
that for it
and i mean my family was worried and
i just knew it was it was honestly
probably a total of three months or it
was
that bad um and then i just got to a
point where i was like
okay i i cannot live like this anymore
or i'm just going to keep going downhill
and i will i would never survive that
so i had to move back in with a friend
on his couch and start working at the
restaurants again
and build myself back up to have my own
money to
get my own place to figure out what i
wanted to do i would
try and meet with professors and see
like what can i do and what can i go to
school for and i couldn't find anything
i was super passionate about
and um but i had worked so hard on
myself just like not what i was doing
but who i was and
and what i needed to be happy and it was
a lot of therapy and just
time and that's like you were saying
like with with
breakups and heartbreaks and they're all
different like i've gone through
breakups where i'm like
great like i'm gonna this is healthy for
me and i'm i'm out
or i've gone through that one where it
was like rock bottom i didn't think i
would even survive it and it felt like
it felt like my therapist said this to
me actually that he had
it felt worse than him dying because i
knew he was still out there
living without me and i had to process
grief and the loss
and it killed me and um and it honestly
which is so crazy took me probably
four years to get over him it was just
you know
time and which is kind of hard because
to tell someone who's going through
heartbreak that time is what's going to
heal is not exactly what they want to
hear but
that is part of the process yeah
wow what did you learn that you like
what is
in your life now what do you do now that
you weren't doing before like what did
you have to do what
boundaries did you have to create for
yourself um
to know where you were starting to lose
yourself
versus what was normal in a compromise
situation like
what what where how did you get to the
place you are now which honestly looks
like i look at you know you can look at
people from a distance and go
oh that seems really legit that seems
legit
yeah thank you and it was you know what
it was is
realizing how resilient i was and
knowing that i could not because it was
that was in the first
relationship i depended on i could not
make other people responsible for me to
feel fulfilled and and
worthy it's i always wanted somebody
else to make me feel that way instead of
making myself feel that way and
that was it was a it was the therapy and
the
realization of that that got me to where
i feel like i am now
even you know going on the show i you
know i'm in the best place blah blah and
then i go on bachelorette and i get
engaged and i think this relationship
okay this is the one this is the one
yeah
this is why i went through everything
and that relationship
obviously it's one thing to meet
somebody on tv and
you think you're in love and then you go
into the real world and you're like okay
well
we both really love each other but we're
not meshing
but but you are you're engaged so you
feel the need to
to try and try and you just want to make
it work so bad but i was like
i could see myself going down that hole
again of
of the depending on him to make me happy
i started recognizing that
which is also a blessing that i could
recognize that
and i saw it happening again and that's
when i knew it wasn't the right
relationship
wow yeah was it scary i mean
yeah were you doubting yourself yeah it
was terrifying because
one i was like oh i'm gonna let so many
people down that are following me
that believed in our love story um it's
gonna be another failure for me
um i am going to lose this person and
and i'll never
you know find someone again that checks
all the boxes that i need
and i but i started feeling really okay
with
being alone forever i convinced myself i
was like i actually think i'm okay
like i can do this i can totally be by
myself
i have my wine i have my show i have my
friends i have my girlfriends i have a
vibrator i'm fine
yeah exactly i'm fine everything's fine
what more do you need hmm so true
um what do you think it is that
really like are you a hippie
i've got a little hippie in me i think i
heard about you talking about crystals
but like this whole like
i would think about this an energy game
where when you finally
when you want something so bad that you
hold the resistance in an equal way like
if you want something there's an
implication that you are lacking
that you don't have it and so when you
finally actually just set an intention
then just let go
and you just go whatever happens happens
you almost forget about it and then bam
the business shows up the person shows
up the guy shows up the
opportunity shows up and all of a sudden
you're like
it's just flowing so easy like
did that i mean i guess i'm i don't know
i'm putting words in your mouth or not
but
no you're how you found jason yes that
is
i could not have said that better myself
because
okay so i had read a book called um
black no light is the new black and it's
about paying attention to the universe
and aligning yourself and just letting
what is happening happen and i
was in a really obviously like sad phase
and you know just felt so defeated
in relationships and i listened to this
um
this book this audiobook on a four-hour
drive i had and i listened to it
and i was just like crying being like oh
my gosh i so believe in that the whole
everything i've done in my life and
gotten to where i am it's like i've
really manifested a lot of things
and i remember hearing that book and
it's really speaking to me and being
like okay i need to like say these
things out loud and
blah and it was like as soon as
as sean and i don't mean to bash on him
but as soon as he was out of my life
i i let that go and i paid attention to
things happening around me
and just kind of surrendered to what was
happening in my life
and i say this on my podcast too it was
like
my career started falling into place i
started feeling more secure in what i
was doing
i was more present in what i was doing i
met jason when i didn't even think i was
gonna date anyone ever for the rest of
my life i did not expect
to meet somebody so quickly
um i started doing all these renovations
on my house and things just kept feeling
like i was on the right path
and it was just so weird how it all
happened from you know listening to that
audiobook and it was like
almost like the universe was like
slapping me in the face being like do
you see this
and just everything was just like
falling into place
um did you have to do i mean by the way
i'm sure everyone literally is gonna now
get this book or audiobook right because
they're like
that's what you do i mean and a lot of
hard work of course but
and a ton and years of therapy and
self-reflection
and you know all the other things any
other modality you can do
yes um gosh that i mean was there
something from that book that you did
different or was it just the awareness
of letting go um it was a lot a lot of
the awareness of letting go
um a lot of things like i would i guess
i do have a little hippie in me because
i'm like i would go on full moons and
like
burn things oh you're so hippie stop it
crystals full moons burning things
and i love it i love are you cheering
cheers
i love that stuff so much it brings joy
to my life i was burning paulo santo
today
i held crystals and meditated yeah
you know i love meditation too oh do you
really
yes i love meditation i'm i wanna i
wanna
it sounds funny to say i wanna get
better at it because
you can just i mean there's so many apps
and people to walk you through
meditations and stuff but
i think everybody does i don't think
anyone feels like they really know how
to
that's true i think that's true because
nobody's a monk on a mountain
nobody's a monk on a mountain meditating
for six hours a day so
you know like everyone could aspire to
more but it's what works for you so what
works for you
that's true i i like to well first of
all i use the calm app
that i really like that's what i use
today really
which one did you do i did what did i do
today i did um
the seven days of happiness i'm on day
six i think
i just started the first day of first
day of seven for gratitude
oh yes i've done that one it's amazing
um and don't you just love her voice
oh i try to decide if i should play the
guy voice or the girl voice i played the
girl
just play the girl voice yes i i'm
blanking on her name i like
am in love with her and i like tell
jason about her like she's
my like spirit guide she might but
i i love her voice and yeah i used that
and then i also so i
i got a peloton have you do you have one
or have you ever used a pelton
i've bought them for people but i have
not used one yet
okay so i i really love it i actually
used to teach spin at one point in my
wh random career of doing things um and
so i love the spin and then they have
meditations on the app as well so i like
to like do a spin
and i mean the instructors really like
it's like they're speaking to me
sometimes like i've cried on the bike
and then i'll get off and i have one of
those
hanging chairs in my living room like a
little swing and so i'll just go sit in
that after and do a five minute
meditation from the peloton app and i
love it
that's great it doesn't have to be much
i think that's where i would get
overwhelmed
or i'd feel like because again i'm
pretty hippie so i'd be like unless i
can go through my breathing techniques
unless i can get to this place where i
get visions and downloads and whatever
like
what's the point but you know i was just
listening to something that there the
other day i don't know if you ever
listen to abraham hicks like
i listen to youtube videos a lot and so
i love the messaging of abraham hicks
because it's all about energy
now she's like all you need to do 15 20
minutes a day that's all you need to do
and all you need to find not all 20
minutes but just one of those minutes if
you can just
get really quiet like really silence
your mind
it's enough and i was like okay that's
all you need to hear sometimes
is that like because again we nobody's
really
like saying like oh i know how to
meditate i'm really good at it you're
like am i i don't know i'm doing it
right
but to hear that you just need to take
away a minute from even a 15-minute
meditation like that just changed my
life with meditation you saying you're
telling me that
yeah yeah and i thought that's so true
because the benefit of just
it's almost like if you it's the way i
envisioned it was
a reset like that one minute is the
reset it really took the 15 to get there
right or whatever it was but it's just
the reset once you can get there it's
like a drop out and start over is what
it kind of felt like for me
so yeah yeah so i think with that
mindset i'll be more consistent too but
it's all about a practice right i mean i
think that that's like just
like with anything with self-improvement
it's about regiment it's about
you know therapy it's about journaling
it's about you know the regularity of it
so just like with meditation it's you
you know you tend to
i think it's one of those things that
you'll get better and better at i'll get
better and better at
as i just make it more routine you'll
find a way to drop in easier like just
like abraham hicks you know
yes when esther becomes abraham for
people who don't know
abraham hicks is actually the channeled
name
for esther hicks which is the human
being
so um she drops in through
i guess it would be like meditation or
trance or
she would say aligning her frequency
with that
of abraham and then the words come
through
as the collective energy called abraham
and so yeah and then you know she you
know she's just so
um she's so she gets there really quick
obviously she does public speaking all
the time so once you get enough practice
i think we'll get better at dropping in
quicker
yeah it's true and like even even as i
do these meditations
i it's making me more aware
through my day like i'll remember
something she said
through my day which it didn't really
click in the moment but i'll remember
something through the day or just like
like the gratitude one i got the five
minute
gratitude journal and it's just like
every morning every night you just write
down a few things
that you that would make your day great
a few things that you're grateful for
and that at the end of the night
a few great things that happened today
and what you hope for tomorrow and it's
just like
even just the practice of that i think
i've been doing it for
maybe two months i mean since the
pandemic started i was like i gotta
write in a journal
and i feel like even just from doing
that practice
ah you can ask my boyfriend he's
literally like you are a different
person like i'm just i'm way more
grateful and and positive in my days
i'm also reading a book by joe dispenza
called breaking the habit of being
yourself
which i feel like sounds so negative
right most people will be like i love
myself i don't want to be a different
person but
you know the intention is is that you're
creating a an
elevated version of yourself you're
highlighting the good things and so
it would be through those things too of
like thinking positive thoughts
and um what he would say in the book so
far i'm about halfway through it
and the last section is on meditation
which i was like once i get to that
that's when i'll feel like i'll really
like force myself to make a good
practice of it
but he would say that you need to
create feel the feeling
of a state beyond where you're at right
so if you're in despair
right you need to think everything's
going to be okay i'm feeling good
i can see the future in a positive way
you have to like
feel it at an elevated point to where
you're at you have to feel greater than
your reality to create a new personal
reality
to then create a new personality wow i
love that
so that's kind of what it feels like to
me with your like writing down how you
want the day to go
writing down what you're grateful
writing down how you want the next day
to go
all you're doing is creating a state
that's potentially beyond where it's at
or at least creating something that's
where you want it to be
right in your mind and and i feel like
as soon as i write things down
that like has the potential to be true
like that's how
i did a vision board about 10 years ago
about where i wanted to be at
and i mean at that time i was it was
before i
you know moved to germany or lost myself
and i just said i wanted my own radio
show i said i wanted to be an
entrepreneur i said i wanted to somehow
get on tv
for being myself and it was crazy all
these things i had written out
and i forgot i even wrote that my
girlfriend actually sent it to me
said not the paper but she sent me a
photo
of me when i was writing it all down she
was like i knew i took this picture for
a reason i just found it
and this was you writing down all of
these things and we had talked about
them and i was like
holy crap i've broken another one have
you done another one since
um yes so i actually did one through my
last breakup
and it's hilarious looking at it now
because it was like oh
okay i didn't know what happened that
soon but like it had golden retrievers
on there
it had a guy that jason is literally
everything that i had i've said this on
my podcast so many times but
i said if i could find a guy that has 60
of what i just wrote down like that
would be a miracle
and he has like 95.
like the only thing i was like i just
don't want to date a bachelor guy and
he's about
but like that was it and like different
things i'm like reading it back
i'm like oh my gosh that and that was
two years ago and so it's
i i truly believe in like the power of
manifesting and writing your thoughts
down and and
believing in what you're what you're
putting out there
i agree yeah what um
what's on your manifesting board what
what hasn't come through yet
but it's funny because dancing with the
stars was on my manifest board five
years ago
and i i was supposed to go on the show
five years ago and i just thank my lucky
stars that it didn't happen because i
was not in a place to just go back on
television
i was not in the right mental space
everything um
and so i've always never lost that dream
and it's just so crazy that now i'm like
i mean i thought i gave up on my dream
of dancing at 26 and here i am at 35
going into dancing with the stars and
i'm just like
again manifested that and
the the thing that i mean now what i
look at and what i would rate on my next
vision board would be like
eventually maybe like um you know
selling my scrunchie brand or
like um obviously having a family like i
did that i was like oh did you do that
what did that
yes that is are you very intuitive
i mean it's one of those weird things to
like say
i'm very intuitive but uh women are
intuitive in general but i feel like you
have good intuition but um yeah i i
honestly like
i spoke to a medium the other day and
she said i have
a baby that's ready when i am and i was
like really because i worry sometimes
about like
i'm 35 and i don't see like i'm not
going to have a baby anytime soon i'm
going i'm dancing and i don't know
what's going to happen but like
she was like oh no this baby is going to
be ready for you
whenever you're ready and i was like
what
so and you froze your eggs too right and
i froze my eggs yes i did too
you did yeah how old were you i was
31 okay i remember asking at around 31
32 and they're like you have plenty of
time i'm like i don't think you get it
like i drive race cars at 220 miles an
hour like
i don't think you get it it's not going
in the belts and
i don't know where my life's going
because i keep dating people that don't
want to commit
and so um i don't think you get it
so at 33 i finally did it and i'm glad
because here i am at 38.
do you want to know what my prediction
is when people date people that don't
want to commit i think it says
that you are just always growing and
evolving
as a person and learning more about
yourself and you're just like
you're becoming more and more of who you
want to be and the people that don't
want to commit are too afraid of that
and they get stuck in their own ways and
and they don't grow so they want to hold
you back from doing that so they can't
commit
that's what i think i think you're
pretty intuitive too
[Music]
i think i am i think it does i think
growth scares people and literally my
only
i have two missions in this life and i'm
not sure if i want to change them
because they kind of keep
making my life really hard um but growth
and truth i don't think there's anything
else to strive for
like if you're continually growing then
you're evolving and i'm learning life
lessons and
surely that just like i think that it
creates bigger peaks and valleys of like
your joy is more in a blissful state of
joy you're able to sort of access that
but i also think that you feel so much
deeper that things are
even more difficult um and then so then
the the thing that weaves into that is
truth which
doesn't always feel good either no and
there's so many people out there that
i mean that don't it's like they don't
want to grow
or get to know themselves better because
they're scared of what they're gonna
realize
and that only just stunts them
in their own happiness and and
they will never change and i i think
i'm similar to you where i like to keep
learning about myself
and practicing certain things and
getting spiritual and doing all that
because
i've seen the benefit of it over the
last however many years so
i i just don't think i don't think
there's a lot of people out there that
or maybe there are but like there's a
lot of people that don't
practice that and that are scared of
their own truth and so then it becomes
oh
they can't commit but that's just an
excuse it is an excuse
yeah it is an excuse and i'm freaking
over it yeah
yeah no kidding because you keep growing
yeah yeah it's true especially last year
yeah yeah what
um that's good though you you are
probably
in such a um good place with yourself to
go
through hard times like i i remember my
last breakup
i was like oh am i going to be a
complete disaster mess have to move back
in with my parents
and i handled it like a champ because i
was so secure in myself and what i
wanted and what i needed
and it helped me through that breakup
yeah
between that family friends and
knowing yourself and just knowing your
own self-worth
you know after that is really just a
matter of making a vision board
obviously
yes that's what you need to do now i
obviously need a vision board yeah um
i've always been so
um impressed with like your
vulnerability
i don't think there's very many people
like that i i know there's not really
the real
authentic like not always pretty
like it's so endearing
and i just has that ever been a struggle
or is that so natural to you
it's it's pretty thank you for saying
that but it's pretty natural
um i think that has a lot to do with my
parents just always encouraging me to be
who i am and feel how i feel
and and i've kind of always gone about
life that way
just being i'm very i've always been
like very open
um being open has also been part of my
humor
and i just i i
know that growing up for me i would have
loved to see somebody in my position
that i you know i have a lot of young
girls following me i would have loved to
see somebody being
um vulnerable for me to look up to
because
for for me i'm looking at magazines of
perfection
and you know there was an instagram but
there's magazines
and i would have loved for somebody to
just be super raw
um to look up to so i was like oh that's
that's just who i am and now i want to
be able to
you know be real with the people that
follow me because otherwise
i'm gonna just get emotionally exhausted
trying to be someone else
and it was funny because so many people
have pointed that out in me or
oh you're just so real or you're so
authentic and i'm like what is that
is that like not a normal thing and then
as i got more involved in where i'm at
i'm like no it's really not like
something that you come by a lot which
is
i mean to me i'm like we are all
you know we all have insecurities we all
have our things that we
are demons or whatever you know our
shadows and
and to me it's like i just feel so much
better when i talk about them
that's why you've manifested the life
that you have that's why you're a
manifesto
yeah yeah right you're not being held
back by
fears yeah you buy them you give them no
power
that's very true yes i don't give them
power and
and not to say i have no fears because i
am right because we're all humans
a lot of things and have a lot of fears
going back on tv again but like
i'll talk about that and like you said
like i don't want to give them
power yeah because that's resistance
exactly and resistance doesn't get you
where you want to go
no yeah not at all um
speaking of resistance i was so excited
when i saw the other day on your stories
and you talking about working out and
going on your fitness journey and like
starting
getting a trainer and doing all this
stuff and you know i
i mean and you also talk about cooking
and i would say if there's two things
that i'm really good at
i work out and i love cooking and i'm
pretty really oh
gosh i wish we lived in the same city
yeah well you know i've got a lot of
time on my hands so if you need
a trainer and a drinking partner i know
i always want your yoga stuff and i'm
like
you are so strong
i i work at it and you know driving race
cars was hard but
um what's that like i just want to hear
what you're doing because
i i'm just kind of obsessed with all
modalities of fitness and nutrition
and like what are you doing how much
long like how long do you have between
knowing you're going to be on the show
and when it starts
yeah so i found out june 4th that i was
going on
immediately got a trainer and then i
don't know specific dates yet they just
said the fall
and i'm thinking september because
obviously they can't
really date out there because of
everything but
um so i think it'll be i think it'll be
september
but i i've always enjoyed some
aspect of fitness but it was always
dance for me growing up and i never
really
i never really was one to do anything
for exercise besides dance because that
was always enough for me to do
uh and then i mean once going to germany
and getting into the crossfit thing i
was like oh i like feeling strong
and uh i didn't i didn't love the
workouts but i loved feeling strong
yeah and then um i actually got really
into yoga for a little while i was going
to teach at the studio
but um i i don't remember why that
didn't work out there was a certain
reason like
they manifested something else that was
better yes
exactly there was something else and so
i
now i know i like to feel strong and
i've gotten i mean
there's body shamers in all sorts of
bodies and um
i mean i've just been teased since i was
little for being like too scrawny
and it was just always something that
really bugged me
and so i love feeling strong and i work
out to
to feel strong and so i was like i'm
gonna get a trainer that like trains
athletes like
i'm not gonna joke around i'm gonna get
a serious trainer and so
this guy kevin klug um his his twin
brother played for the titans and he was
a trainer for
some some of the athletes and he's done
some of the hockey players and
i mean i was very intimidated going in
because i'm like
i don't like my arms like people call
them little twigs like i'm like i don't
know how much i'm gonna be able to lift
or a squat but like i'm
i'm so determined my trainer always says
you've got
dog in you because i'm like i will work
so hard
and uh so yeah now i've been doing you
know like
lifting some pretty serious weights
doing pull-ups and
training really hard and then my other
friend worth who's in town here he has a
gym called true mav
and he opened it with tim mcgraw and
it's like the best kind of workout so he
was helping me a lot too and he's a dear
friend and
so i've just been like i also love
boxing because it makes me feel
so strong and badass and yeah i've just
kind of been going back and forth
between my peloton boxing
lifting weights and just trying to like
do all sorts of different workouts to
get strong
for uh for going well i mean for myself
but i want to
not injure myself going on right well
you want to be you want to be strong
enough to do like any kind of like
lifting and you know flailing around and
but i think more than anything
it seems like you need stamina because
dancing but you know that see i think
that you
you probably have the mindset for
stamina in a dance environment to go for
hours and hours
so you know i kind of think yeah i kind
of think you probably didn't even need
to work out if i'm being honest
i don't know about that i i i mean i did
because i realized how weak
my muscles were and going into i went to
a
um physical therapist and she was doing
like you know um
mobility and muscle testing and she was
like
okay this is really weak and that's not
good for going into dancing and i was
like okay let's work on that
so i feel like i'm really prepared and
i'm gonna like laugh
so hard at myself if i get sent home
night one
you're not because you're a dancer and
actually a long time i remember
uh elio castroneves he was an indycar
driver and he was on like one of the
first couple of seasons really
he won and he's every hard driver so
he was partners with julianne huff oh
she's incredible yeah
yeah i mean that's one she's she is
so talented yeah yeah she is for sure
um but i know you're going to be good i
have no doubt that you're going to be
very good
you're going to look amazing you're
going to be
yeah you haven't you you can you got
kind of like a little bit of an upper
hand
yeah i put that okay that's what i'm
afraid of though i think people are
going to think i have an upper hand and
then i'm going to look like a fool
because i've never done ballroom before
so i'm going to be like oh this is
like because hannah who is the last
bachelorette she just won
and she said you have to unlearn almost
everything that you know about dance
because now it's like they don't do
eight counts they don't
everything's like heel toe for some
steps but toe heel for others
and she said it was so much harder than
she thought it was gonna be
it reminds me telling that story of like
because you know dance you're
afraid that's going to be different it
reminds me of watching chopped
have you ever watched chops before if
you like to cook maybe you have yeah
um and then chopped i always felt like
whenever there was a pastry chef that
made it to the dessert round
they lost yes because they were like oh
shoo in i'm a pastry chef like i'm of
course gonna do this
uh do amazing and then they didn't yeah
and see and i feel like because i know
uh your dog's barking mine's kicking my
back right now
like i think this is like what they call
like uh signs uh that we wrap it up
i it's so funny every time i'm getting
ready to wrap up a podcast
pino will usually come up here and just
start crawling on me it's like he knows
that's so funny what was the last thing
oh um
i already forget that's okay we're
drinking
and my glass is almost done oh my gosh
this
goes to show my glasses not almost done
and that's because i've been talking way
too much i'm so
it's so weird being a guest on
somebody's podcast because it's
i'm i'm like i feel so selfish i'm like
well can we talk about you like what
about you
i i mean i came from the other way where
it was like i was
always interviewed so when i started
doing podcasts i am
so used to my pups right here um i'm
so used to sharing my stories like on
and on and on and of course that's the
point like
that's what that's what tv wants you to
do right and um
so i actually had to shut up i actually
had to learn how to shut up because i
was like wow i
sound so conceited and i
sound i sound horrible telling all these
stories i need to be quiet no i think
part of going into hosting is you want
to be a good host so you want the
conversation to always go and it brings
up
topic thoughts and you're just like oh i
got to say this so you talk over the
people like
yeah you know how it is yeah well this
dog's
deaf that's at the door right now so
even if i said hey ricky stop barking
he wouldn't because he's deaf oh okay so
i guess
we know what's cheers and good luck with
dancing with the stars
you're wonderful and i'm so glad that
this this happened
um i wish it could have been in person
but damn you coveted
yeah i know we'll we'll make it happen
one time okay
and if not then i'll have to just bring
a case of wine some
you know i've got red i've got rose i
just made a white that just got bottled
yesterday
we'll just have to taste test yes you
are killing it you are so incredible
thank you for having me on and i
honestly would love to have you on mine
um sometime as well
not a problem just let me know when
awesome cheers good luck thank you
yes thank you i'm like is that is that
how we end or
somebody come on now and say i think we
just go like this and we're like
perfect you're too cute okay
thank you so much thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today i hope you enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button